ARIZONA COYOTES IN HIS CAREER.
CAN STARS EARLY ON.
THE COYO AND GETS A REBOUND
YOU HAVE TO FIND SOME OFFENSE I
A HURRY TONIGHT.
ALREADY DOWN 1YTON TURNS IT THE
WERE ABLE TO ADD AN EMPTY NET
GOAL EMPTY NET G GET A GOOD LOO
BAR AND THE STICK AND WHERE HE
MAKES CONTACT WITH THE POCK RIG
THE STICK OF ROUSSEL.
LINEUP. TAKE THAT ASSISTST
THEY NEED OFFENSE FROM HIM AS T.
HE CONTINUES TO GET IT DONE AT
DALLAS STARS..
KICKED A LONG.
KELLER NEED A SHOT.
>> Matt: GOSTISBEHERE WITH A
SHOT
NOW LYUBUSHKIN WILL GET A WHIST
STOPPAGE OF PLAY.
PLAYED OUT HIGH FOR LINDELL.
UNTOUCHED
COYOTES.E OF CLAYTON KELLER.
CLAYTON KELLER ZIPPING IT AROUND
.
HE WILL FIND KESSEL AND COMES I
FOR A CLEAR.
INSTEAD HEN THE LEGS OF HOLTBY.
I DON'T THINK HE
THAT IS WHY WE TALK ABOUT ROOPE
HINTZ AT THE START OF THE GAME R
.
KELLER WORKING IT BACK OUT HIGH.
GOSTISBEHERE TAKES A A
>> Matt: HOLTBY WITHOUT HIS
STICK ABLE TO MAKE
FIVE GOALS TIES A CAREER HIGH
FOR HIM HE'S H H IN THE FIRST.
THEY HAVE GOT DEPTH. THE SHOOTI.
RIGHT NOW.
TRAILING BY ONE WITH 10:13
REMAINING.
CROUSE HAS GUIDED.
DONE ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
HE CHIPS IT IN AND TAKES A HIT.